en las últimas semanas el gobernador de
texas greg abbott había enviado más de
6000 inmigrantes indocumentados a la
capital del país a washington y muchos
de ellos habían venido aquí a nueva york
pero este es el primer autobús que llega
directamente desde texas con inmigrantes
indocumentados lazio a primera hora de
la mañana en la parada de autobuses de
la autoridad portuaria allí les han
recibido varios voluntarios que les han
ayudado a subir a unos taxis serán
llevados a un centro donde se procesarán
a ser les recogerán los datos y de allí
irán a un centro de acogida para
descansar esta ha sido la última
respuesta del gobernador texano a la
política de fronteras abiertas dice el
que va a ir en el presidente está
llevando a cabo dice que están
desbordados con la llegada de
inmigrantes y aprovechando un poco el
ofrecimiento y burlándose también de
alguna manera que hizo el alcalde de la
ciudad de nueva york eric adams que dijo
que nueva york es una ciudad santuario
que acogerá a todos los inmigrantes que
lleguen pues los está enviando aquí de
momento el alcalde adams no ha dado
ningún respuesta pública pero ya lleva
varios días diciendo que efectivamente
nueva york es una ciudad santuario y que
siempre recibirá con los brazos abiertos
a los inmigrantes eso sí le pide a
washington recursos le pide ayuda para
poder frente a hacer frente a toda esta
avalancha de inmigrantes que están
llegando porque lo cierto es que los
albergues de acogida aquí están
saturados ya ha habido bastantes
problemas la última semana porque
algunos de los migrantes que llegaron
procedentes de washington han tenido que
dormir en la calle y están preocupados y
desde las autoridades de la ciudad y han
dicho que va a ser necesario abrir más
centros de acogida para poder dar cobijo
a toda esta avalancha de migrantes que
está llegando desde texas y que ahora
podría aumentar porque también ha dicho
el gobernador de arizona que se va a
sumar a esta acción